[Music]  i doubled my travelling time  as an hr director i cannot do everything  from remote  and i had special work to do in germany  so for me it was really important to get  there on a weekly basis  when the border restrictions were  starting i still had a lot of meetings  planned that i would have to cancel  because i had to take a train  and at the same time it was also  necessary that i got a studio  in hamburg so i could live there and  stay overnight  playing it will take about three hours  from door to door  however by train it takes at least six  hours traveling by train definitely  changed my schedule and i really would  have to book  my meetings according to what is  possible i cannot for example have  confidential conversations in the train  my wish for the future of schengen  borders is that they will open up  completely again  so that traveling both by plane or train  or car will be as easy as it used to be  you